while the leaders of other countries are
focused on
you know making their militaries into
more effective and deadlier fighting
machines which thrive at the central
task of killing the enemy
the folks in charge of our military have
an entirely different set of priorities
it would seem
for them america's greatest adversary
isn't china
or any other world power but intolerance
and the best way to defeat intolerance
is through the promotion of
diversity and inclusion
now once you understand that these are
the new priorities of a military that
has long been a petri dish for leftist
social experimentation
the events of this past week become
slightly more comprehensible
um with without this background
understanding it might seem shocking and
bewildering
that a search for the phrase military
leaders in google's news tab
delivers not articles about those
leaders developing devastating new
battlefield technology or doing anything
else to make the u.s
safer and more secure but dozens of
headlines like this
one from the military times it says
senior leaders
dunk on tucker carlson's misogynistic
comments about maternity flight suits
nbc news tucker carlson slammed by
military leaders
for mocking pregnant service members
yahoo news
pentagon takes unprecedented shot at
tucker carlson
for dissing military diversity
this is what the pentagon is focused on
the crisis that's attracted the
attention of these fearless warriors
is as the headline suggests a
politically
incorrect opinion expressed by a cable
news host
on his show a few days ago tucker
carlson had an appropriately derisive
reaction to president biden's remarks on
international women's day
where biden discussed his plans to get
more women involved in combat including
pregnant women
and part of his plan biden said is to
offer maternity flight suits and to
update hairstyle requirements
here's biden explaining you know
some of some of it's relatively
straightforward work
where we're making good progress
designing
body armor that fits women properly
tailoring combat uniforms for women
creating maternity flight suits and
updating
updating requirements for their
hairstyles
and some of it is going to take and
uh you know an intensity
of purpose and mission to really change
the culture and habits
that cause women to leave the military
that women are making sure more diverse
candidates are considering
being considered for career advancing
opportunities
at every single level the women aren't
penalized
in their careers for having children
that women aren't just
token members but integral parts
throughout all branches and all
divisions
that vacant look once again a carlson's
point about these plans is simply that
they don't seem designed to actually
make the military better
at what the military is supposed to do
protect the country
and kill the enemy these are changes
based not on science and data but
ideology
here's here's tucker so we've got
new hairstyles and maternity flight
suits pregnant women are going to fight
our wars
it's a mockery of the us military while
china's military becomes more masculine
as it's assembled the world's
largest navy our military needs to
become as joe biden says more feminine
whatever
feminine means anymore since men and
women no longer exist
the bottom line is it's out of control
and the pentagon is going along with
this again this is a
mockery of the us military and its core
mission which is winning wars
he's totally right of course
and it's likely the fact that he's right
which provoked military leadership to go
into defcon one
the command senior enlisted leader of
the united states space command master
gunnery sergeant scott h stalker
posted a video on twitter blasting
tucker for causing drama
and arguing that the cable host has no
military experience also stalker noted
the decision to include more pregnant
women in the armed forces
was made by medical experts here's uh
some of that let's listen
let me tell you where he's wrong those
decisions were made by medical
professionals by commanders
and our civilian leadership that allows
for women to have more time with their
children
to recuperate to get fit and ready
to take that time that's necessary that
our medical professionals know is needed
which match actually makes us a more
lethal and ready and fit force
ready to fight the wars of today and the
wars of tomorrow
the bottom line is that we value women
in our in our armed forces we value the
those that have served in the past and
we value those that have served today
we value our families in the military
i want to say god bless everyone that is
serving today god bless the women that
are serving today god bless the men and
women
that are serving today god bless our
country our partners
and our allies let's get back to work
let's remember
that those opinions were made by an
individual who has never served a day
in his life let's remember that's all
about drama tv
god bless america semper fidelis now the
problem with this argument is that it's
beside the point the fact that tucker's
never served in the military does not
preclude him from making common sense
observations about the military and by
the way this whole
thing about how you you can't criticize
military
policy unless you served in the military
so what you're saying is you can't
criticize the government unless you've
worked for it
uh i'm not sure i'm a fan of that i'm
not sure that's the most american in
fact i would say that's about the most
anti-american opinion you could possibly
express
and the fact that medical experts said
it's okay to have pregnant women
piloting aircraft
doesn't mean that it's better or even
good to have more pregnant women
piloting aircraft
i don't care if they said it's okay what
does it have to do with anything
who gives a damn about that the first
and primary
primary question the people running our
military whether civilian or enlisted
should be asking is whether any given
change will help to make the military
into a more lethal fighting force
that should be the motivation behind
every change because that's the
fundamental purpose of the military
the problem isn't just that the abide
administration wants to include women in
the military
they've already been included for
decades so we're way past that
it's that he wants to take active steps
to recruit more and more women
and get more of them involved in in
combat at every level
and so again we have to ask will this
make the military
better at killing the bad guys
we're not asking did the medical experts
say it's okay
we're not asking about diversity will
this make
the military better at killing the bad
guys
if if if america was going to war with
an enemy
and you could choose between fighting an
enemy with a with a military comprised
100 percent of men
or military comprised 50 of men or 50 of
women which would you choose
to fight against
does it make the military better at
killing the bad guys when you include
more women
the answer to that question is pretty
clearly no now we can arrive at this
conclusion
through the employment of basic common
sense uh those who require studies to
confirm common sense judgments will be
interested to know
that the studies do indeed find that
exactly what sensible people would
expect them to find
as npr reported in 2015 quote a
year-long marine corps study trying to
understand how gender integration
would affect combat readiness has found
that all male units were faster
more lethal and able to evacuate
casualties in less time
overall according to a summary of the
study all male squads performed better
than mixed groups in 69
of the tasks evaluated faster and more
lethal
all male squads are faster and more
lethal because men in general
are faster and more lethal this probably
explains why the navy seals opened their
ranks to women years ago
but still no woman has managed to become
one
only the fastest and most lethal can
make it through and no woman has ever
been able to get over that bar
now admittedly i also say this is
someone who like carlson did not serve
but it seems to me that when it comes to
the u.s military
faster and more lethal is good
tell me if i'm wrong i'm i didn't serve
in the military that's that's
what it seems to me that it's good if i
had to choose between
making the military faster and more
lethal or making it slower and less
lethal
i would choose faster and more lethal
that's that seems better to me
if increased efforts to recruit and
evolve more and more women
will have the effect of making our
fighting forces slower and less lethal
then those efforts are bad it's that
simple
now if the other side of this argument
has evidence that in fact women make the
military more lethal
then they ought to present it you just
heard there he claimed he said
this is including pregnant women and
giving them time off with their kids
is all part of making us a more lethal
fighting force really
how so can you explain that
i'm going to need a little bit more than
that
but the really troubling fact is that
the other side isn't actually interested
in having an argument about what
policies will make the military better
at killing the enemy to them
killing the enemy ought not be the
central function of the institution at
all
general jacqueline van ovost also
responded to tucker carlson and
explained quote there are nearly 70 000
qualified kick-ass female
airmen from the u.s air force airmen for
years we have evolved and will continue
to evolve
shedding antiquated policies preventing
any woman from reaching their full
potential
inclusion is our strength it'll be the
difference between winning and losing
inclusion is our strength this of course
is madness
if inclusion is our strength then why
have boot camp
why have any physical or performance
standards at all
why have elite units like the seals and
the rangers
the point in all of those cases is to
exclude
to weed out the weakest and the least
capable
for the first two centuries of our
nation's existence back when our
military was toppling empires
and winning world wars it was thought
that our strength
was strength we had the baddest and
toughest the most well-trained men
and the best strategic minds to lead and
guide them and that's how we achieved
world-changing victory after
world-changing victory
but that was back when things were
allowed to have a purpose that
transcended the political
the left will not permit such trifles
anymore now
all things in their control let's face
it the military is one of those things
have the primary purpose of advancing
the leftist ideological agenda
so we will go out of our way to get
women even pregnant women into fighter
jets and onto the battlefield
and we'll recruit transgender people and
pay for their sex changes with tax money
and do 100 other things that will in no
way make us stronger or safer as a
nation
because the powers that be have decided
that is no longer the military's job
to be a military if they are to be
warriors anymore they must be
they must be warriors of the social
justice variety
and that's how it's going to go at least
until we're invaded and conquered
and for all of those reasons the people
running our military
starting at the top with joe biden are
certainly without a doubt
cancelled listen hit that subscribe
button
right now do it right now i thank you
for your compliance
it is somewhat appreciated